pensemos ahora en reagrupar los números
decimales y lo que quiero es ver cuántas
posibilidades de valor tenemos con el
siguiente número vamos a escribirlo
tendremos 20 1.3 y lo estoy poniendo con
diferentes colores porque vamos a
trabajar con ello si nosotros le
escribimos esto sería igual a 2 en el
lugar de las decenas o 20
20 más una unidad
más tres décimos
tenemos exactamente lo mismo y lo
queremos con reagrupar será lo siguiente
qué pasa si este uno
lo quito de aquí y lo envío hacia los
décimos tendría entonces aquí cero
y estaré enviando diez décimos
la unidad
para añadirlo a los tres décimos que
tenemos entonces esto sería reescribir
le de la siguiente manera
veinte o dos decenas más cero unidades
por qué
reagrupado s 1 + 10 décimos de esta
unidad que reagrupe en las décimas más
los tres décimos originales que teníamos
y reescrito esto en su totalidad con la
suma de estos décimos será 20 más
13 décimos y tiene sentido porque 21.3
no puedo contar como 20 más 13 décimos o
como 20 más 10 décimos más tres décimos
o 20 más precio décimos de cualquier
manera es 21.3 hagamos otro ejemplo y
ahora tomaré desde las decenas de
escribir esto 21.3
pero ahora tomaré una unidad de las
decenas se convertirá en un 1 y esta
decena que estoy reagrupando hacia
unidades y decimos la separará de la
siguiente manera le daré 9 a las
unidades para que esto se convierta en
un 10 y le daré 1 de ese 10 a los
décimos para obtener entonces 13 decimos
vamos a reescribir lo para que sea mucho
más evidente tendré 10 decenas más 9 más
donde esté 9 lo reagrupar eh con las
unidades y este uno lo reagrupar con los
decimos vamos ahora con las unidades
como lo tenemos más uno más tres decimos
lo único que hice fue reescribirlo estos
20 dividirlos entre 10 más 91 que suman
20 más una de las unidades más tres
décimas
ahora como les comentaba estos nueve
los reagrupar con las unidades por eso
los colocó en magenta y este uno
los reagrupar con los décimos por eso lo
pongo en anaranjado así que hagamos este
reagrupamiento tendremos entonces 10 en
las decenas más
9 más 110 en las unidades
más
este uno será diez décimos
más tres décimos
tendremos una vez más lo reescribir en
10 más
10 unidades más 13 décimos y de esta
manera podemos tener escrito de
diferentes formas nuestro mismo número
simplemente reagrupado en las unidades y
en los décimos de distintas maneras nos
vemos en otro vídeo